des armes utilisées par la police qui
ressemble de plus en plus à de l'arsenal
militaire
des armes intermédiaires qui devraient
épargner des vies mais qui nous mettent
en danger
si à part formation pour garder le
chemin pacifique
la réponse naturelle c'est de répondre
avec la violence
c'est pas une méthode de contrôle de
foule d'autres séries sur le monde
presque six ans après le printemps
érables des témoignages et des vidéo
nous montre les fesses ou un nouvel
éclairage
notre collègue sylvie fournier a
poursuivi son enquête et découvert des
éléments qui remettent en question la
version policière des événements pour le
france peut résulter mais ces symboles
qui a taxé paul pélissier
c'était pas capable de comprendre cet
appât d'affaires nouveau classé d-box
inc
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
c'est une des toutes premières
manifestations du printemps érables et
une des toutes premières aussi dans les
villes de france s grenier le 7 mars
il fait partie d'un groupe d'étudiants
de saint-jérôme venus protester contre
la hausse des frais de scolarité sont
tous contents pouvoir à la manifestation
c'est très festif
j'avais apporté une arme nucléaire des
manifestants bloquent l'entrée de
l'immeuble qui abrite la conférence des
recteurs d'universités la crepuq les
policiers donnent l'ordre de se
disperser
mon
[Applaudissements]
mais les manifestants ne partent pas il
est riche d'une barricade avec des
clôtures trouvait dans la rue on a vu
que bon ça va bosser on la regarde la
télévision
après ça on a vu les fameuses bon les
policiers optent pour la méthode forte
ils lancent des grenades assourdissantes
dr bbg une bombe qui dégagent une petite
quantité de gaz lacrymogène et génère
100 75 décibels c'est au dessus du seuil
de la douleur
les étudiants sont ensuite repoussées
vigoureusement d'une première salve
on a couru et pour s'éloigner la foule
ou by many policy humaniser ou de la
force
deuxième salve au lieu et c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai été blessé
je suis mon visage j'ai regardé ma main
je voyais du sein sont amis
[Musique]
c'est angoissant
jag aucune dit qu'est ce qui se passe au
niveau de même si on savait que je
voyais pas tellement le droit
[Musique]
il devra marcher trois coins de rues
avant qu'une ambulance le prennent en
charge
on approche a du talent beaucoup de
tontouta parce que bon mag était
beaucoup plus blessé que compass est un
fragment de grenades assourdissantes a
déchiré sa paupière et a causé un
décollement de la rétine
cette photo circule sur facebook le soir
même vers 21h des policiers se
présentent à l'hôpital a les arsenaux et
l'avocat de francis grenier il est ce
son lit d'hôpital
pierre deux policiers qui arrivent et
qui est ce ce qu'est ce qui est si ça
plaît le père de francis grenier du
personnel infirmier ils n'ont même
cachet des policiers pourquoi que pour
coder les policiers cessent de l'arsenic
leur ai demandé s'ils avaient plein est
apportée non non non mais parce que pour
notre enquête policière
c'était dérogatoire alors que le blessé
n'a commis aucun crime est un abus de
pouvoir estime m r se noue local droits
cédés personnes en exercice de leur
fonction qui vont n'ont pas enquêté sur
les crimes la tête poisson est clair il
veut juste savoir que ce qui repousse
trouver un système de défense
la police dira que francis grenier a été
blessé par un morceau de glace ou
d'installer lancés par d'autres
manifestants
on voit pourtant que la grenade est
lancée trauma et qu'elle explose dans la
foule
[Applaudissements]
faites une erreur pas du tout ils ont
plaidé préfet comme si de rien n'était
c'est seulement compte interrogatoire
qu'on a réussi à obtenir des
informations comme quoi qu'il va changer
de politique sans le décret aujourd'hui
on éviterait de lancé ses grenades ou
déçus de la tête des manifestants mais
la police a pris soin de ne laisser
aucune trace écrite de ce qui a motivé
ce changement recommandé on a débriefé
il n'y a rien d'écrit l'autruche en
plein carême et plus je vous et pour
cause elle parce que est un organisme
public n'accourt de loi d'accès à
l'information les informations quand il
faut qu'ils soient transcrits
alors on fait un débriefing on se parle
des vrais shows mais y'a pas toujours
des notes de pluie parce que le système
étant comme il y est il ya des choses
qu'on veut qu'il soit alors ça tout poil
plus transparaître ce que je vous ai
assez de lait au cache des choses au
public aux médias et on essaye un
médecin de camoufler sa responsabilité
civile générale de stratégie de lancer
des grenades assourdissantes python ont
dit que ces pauvres 2 orienter la foule
puis là sur 30 pts sur le dernier chose
que tu feras contrôle de foule m'a
semblé désorienté afful donné ce clap a
été chef d'une équipe d'intervention à
la sûreté du québec pendant 19 ans ils
s'inquiètent des méthodes de contrôle de
foule utilisés par la police
on envoie le dd
et sans athènes de documents vidéo le
sur youtube les policiers qui sont
déplaisants sont des insultes léger
il faire sur tout ce qui bouge pour
compliquer le juste tout ce qui bouge
qui était conseiller pour la commission
ménard est d'avis que certaines salles
comme les grenades assourdissantes
le poivre de cayenne et le bâton p r 24
sont trop dangereuses dans le contexte
d'une manifestation l'au delà qui dans
des coûts et sa pointe à 24
lexus du monde ce qu'il fallait à lui ça
vient chercher sa sauce ce soit dans le
plexus dans le doubs manger la pointe
d'un bâton là quand tu frappes world en
colonne vertébrale se peut de fabriquer
des véritables restée paralysée
c'est aux policiers la nuit à quelques
parler quelqu'un qu'il donnerait sa fin
ou qui a montré que c'est comme ça que
ça marche et c'est un rouleau mais les
deux sont inacceptables
la culture policière qu'il faudrait
changer dit-il de la base jusqu'au
famille a partagé de se doter d'une
philosophie on reconnaît aux gens
doivent manifester la discipline
professionnalisme la retenue l'empathie
tout des éléments qui font que tu bat le
message constant
mais la sphère greny révèle au contraire
que new tunes sur die puni t
quelques mois après l'accident dans un
courriel à ses supérieurs
le lieutenant philippe pichet le futur
chef de police reconnaît que la rb bg la
grenade assourdissante n'est pas sans
danger mais il écarte la mise en garde
du fabricant qu'il compare à un banal
avertissement sur une boîte de céréales
kellogg magit monsieur péché je sais
comment la mise en garde sur une boîte
de céréales
c'est équilibre pour moi qui ai écrit je
peux lui que les cuisses et le fabricant
ça peut tuer ça déjà tué le juge nit
nonn chez les policiers qui ont témoigné
une forte tendance à diminuer ou même
nier le risque dénoncée par le fabricant
lui-même dans l'intérêt de voir la
poursuite échoué il conclut à une faute
de la police et ordonne à la ville de
payer des dommages
je crois que le droit de manifester
quand même on doit fondamentale
il comptera pour l'exercer
or notre sécurité mais alain arsenault
ne crois pas que ce jugement sévère
apportera les changements espérés
purement ok on va payer échec ça va
faire 1 204 me pierre-jean à bayonne
aucune remise en question des façons de
fin des gestes posés par qui que ce soit
si je me fie ce que moi j'entendais
encore ça va peut être un chien ou un
chat que ça pour faire rapporter plus
grave c'est à des dommages collatéraux
la police de montréal a refusé de
commenter le jugement française grenier
n'a pas retrouvé l'usagé de son oeil
pour celui qui rêvait de poursuivre ses
études en arts visuels
c'est une grande déception c'est plus
difficile
le vivement que s'il est avec ses ces
restrictions et j'ai aussi le sentiment
d'être a pu
inférieurs puis à ce que cherche la
cette masse de plus rien car sauf un
oeil puis toulouse a été causée par des
forces de l'ordre la sphère grenier va
se répéter des armes controversées
causeront d'autres blessures graves que
la police tentera de réfuter on aboutit
à des violences extrêmes
particulièrement victoriaville qui était
pour moi un piège extraordinaire on a
abouti à une escalade dû entre autres au
manque de professionnalisme des
policiers et au manque de contrôles du
bouddhisme des années après les
événements de victoriaville des images
et des témoignages
il met 10 apporte un éclairage nouveau
sur ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
on poursuit notre enquête avec notre
collègue sylvie fournier suivi on va
parler des armes d'impact et de ses
fameuses balles en plastique je vous en
ai apporté une pour vous montrez vous
allez voir c'est très dur de dur oui un
silo sujet très vite et ça voyage aussi
à 266 kilomètres à 7 aussi vite qu'une
voiture de formule 1 évidemment les
policiers qui vont tenter de contenir
une émeute qui peuvent pas les mains
vides
absolument c'est certain les policiers
doivent bien avoir des outils ce qui
fait controverse c'est quand on utilise
ces balles en contrôle de foule se dire
dans des manifestations
c'est là qu'elle devienne très dangereux
d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs personnes à
victoriaville en 2012 qui disent avoir
été blessé par ces balles c'est exact
qu'on avait fait à l'époque un reportage
où on faisait la démonstration qu'un
policier avait vraisemblablement à
retirer avant d'en avoir l'autorisation
la police avait racheté un autre
hypothèse mais après plusieurs années
d'enquêté maintenant un policier qui est
citée devant le comité de déontologie
policière
casqués cuirassé par me voici
l'unité d'intervention de la sûreté du
québec plusieurs de ces images
proviennent de la manifestation de
victoriaville en 2012
au plus fort du printemps érable un
événement marquant controversé et dont
on se souvient entre autres parce qu'il
s'est soldée par des blessés graves
on y voit là jean matricule 10 4 7 7 1
des six policiers équipés d'une arme
d'impact il vient d'être blâmé par le
comité de déontologie policière pour
avoir manqué de prudence et de
discernement dans les usages de son arme
rappelons-nous tchèque avec des finances
qui peut être létales dans ces
circonstances que ce mardi que ce danger
public c'est de cette façon d un danger
public
armé de à juan 37
une arme à feu dont les balles de
plastique une bâton cinétique ont une
vitesse de 74 mètres secondes
l'équivalent de 2 166 km 1 elle se situe
juste en dessous de la force mortelle
le policier doit viser une seule
personne pour l'empêcher de poser un
geste pouvant causer des blessures
graves
si je l'atteins sur une jambe c'est
certain que à mon groupe à personne ne
la voyais faire mal à votre analyse mais
si je l'atteins à gorge ou le latin est
un peu importe à ta tempe n'est pas tout
à coup et un de ces ce que le sap est
l'état
le 4 mai 2012 est un vendredi gris et
pluvieux à victoriaville au moins 2000
personnes ont répondu à l'appel d'une
large coalition d'organismes
communautaires et syndicaux pour
manifester le congrès du parti libéral
avait été jugé par les membres de la
coalition à l'assemblée comme un moment
à 16 heures pour aller exprimer notre
position non seulement la hausse des
frais de scolarité mais aux autres
mesures d'austérité mais la police a
enfreint ses propres règles la première
elle n'établit pas de contact avec les
organisateurs de l'événement ya toujours
une personne qui est le contact de des
services de police
et est-ce qu'on lui a répondu à ce
moment là c'est si on a besoin de vous
parler on va vous trouver ne sera
renvoyé pas être comme ça je pense que
c'était jamais arrivé dans une
manifestation de de la coalition
au journal des opérations les policiers
notent à l'avant la présence de
manifestants habillés de noir comme le
black block l'étudiant alexandre allard
lui se trouve au milieu du cortège
j'ai trouvé aussi un parapluie chapeau
dont l'allergie du québec que j'ai mis
ce matin que j'ai eus durant toute la
manifestation
deuxième erreur
le périmètre est mal protégé les
fameuses sculptures retenu avec des
attaches en plastique ne peut pas
laisser souris détail rap c'est très
bien ils manifestaient encore assez seul
et très rapidement la clôture tombe
trois pelotons sont immédiatement
déployés
le petit groupe de manifestants rick est
aussitôt sous quand même
une espèce de sports extrêmes pour
certaines personnes d'aller dans des
manifs puis s'attaquer aux policiers
pour tous au il ya quand même faut pas
perdre de vue que on parle d'une poignée
d'individus
deux autres peloton sont appelés en
renfort dont celui de l'agent buret
jean duret à bâle et les événements
victoriaville lacarrau monter la
dernière fois que vous aviez cv une
vingtaine d'impacts opposé je me suis un
peu souvenez pas
est ce que c'est ça pouvait remonter à
votre qualification opposing depuis sa
qualification
là jean burelle a été affecté 14 fois
avec son arme d'impact mais n'a jamais
tiré comme un bouchon de pratique
au moment où les déployer la
manifestation est déclaré illégal
[Musique]
debout
mais autre erreur le message est noyée
dans le tumulte ambiant
c'est le chaos qu'on sentait qu'au
niveau sonore même s'ils font des appels
tant qu'à moi serait au parloir
c'est pas tout le monde qui veut
l'entendre on avocat mais on avait un
bon système de sonorisation donc c'est
sûr que si on avait une information leur
ai transmis presqu'en même temps des gaz
lacrymogènes sont tirés vers la foule
les gens sont choqués
scandalisé de paiement la police avait
rapidement les garder comme a finalement
la manifestation n'avait pas pu se tenir
là magali paquet mère de deux enfants
était étudiante au doctorat
il n'y a pas eu de gradation en fait
c'est très rapidement on est passé d'une
manifestation tout à fait
conventionnelle bon enfant à une
déploiement c'est intense puis agressif
les personnes qui comprenait ce qui se
passait les parents avec leurs enfants
en poussette se sauvaient parce qu'ils
savaient pas où aller puis quoi faire
les ans en pleurer quand vous soigner
j'ai été aussi surpris
jean pierre roy et membres des
infirmiers et infirmières contre la
hausse le groupe n'est pas là pour
manifester mais pour prodiguer les
premiers soins aux besoins
vous n'avez pas peur pour intervenir
auprès de gens qui étaient équipées
incommodés par des gaz puis on paie pas
capables d'intervenir guettait
nous-mêmes que moi
les manifestants sont repoussés il
déploie une large banderole rouge entre
eux et le cordon policier
18h55 au journal des opérations on note
que le périmètre est maintenant
contrôlée et sécurisé c'est le moment où
l'agent burel puise dans son sac
10 et il il explique avoir voulu
protéger ses collègues je veux changer
un marteau les pierres des morceaux
calmes et des balles pour les morceaux
de bois
vernon tellement dans mes souvenirs à
moins de 7 et constant arrêté pour ce
faire interroge-t-elle salagado nous
bombardait partout mais j'attends platon
son temps à langer que tu te dois te
défendre puis comme je dis ô dieu quand
je te demande au moins 30 départ des
capable de faire des bonnes personnes
mais là jean burelle ne sais pas s'il a
atteint la bonne personne dans le feu de
l'action lors il est allé ou à prayssac
bâton cinétique mois que l'on vous dise
importance n'est fixé quand même assez
rigide ça peut avoir un impact très
dommageable vous d'accord avec moi je
peux vous et la même chose un morceau de
pain et où d'une balle de poules bout
des gants avec moi que c'est vous le
professionnel au rendez vous de même que
c'est moi qui ai le policier oui mais je
donc j'ai formé pour savoir tirer et
pour savoir où vont vos tirs public avec
moi mais love boat choses qui se passent
en à vendre ses pots sont perfectionnés
[ __ ] en face d'eux les gens burel
soutien d'un homme avec un drôle de
chapeau
derrière la banderole rouge qu'est-ce
que vous saisir vraiment pas grand chose
en fait je la tenais c'est sûr c'est
vrai que c'est rien mais finalement on
devrait sacrer une comme protection
imaginales contre les policiers
une protection illusoire au moment où
l'agent duranti alexandre penser qu'on
appelle qui n'était pas strict d'appel
connu c'est quelqu'un un concierge avait
une respiration rapide qui vous
questionner sur quel type de traumatisme
et le pu recevoir
j'espérais sont répétés traumatisme à la
pâte
ça va pas bien que ce que c'est possible
que vous ayez atteint la personne comme
dawson
pas où j'ai donné burelle a tiré dix
balles dans la foule en 30 minutes
ils ignorent ou neuf de ses dix balles
ont terminé leur course et la suite n'a
rien de rassurant
[Musique]
alexandra larvée d'être blessé toute
cette agitation a lieu en face de la
jambe hurel
mais il n'aurait rien vu et toujours
sans savoir s'il atteint sa cible
il tire à nouveau jamais le doute que
son âme soit mal ajustés ne laissèrent
le mac j'ai pas eu le temps de me poser
la question quand je dis le sa part été
monsieur moment donné vous êtes vibre au
rythme de ce qui se passe que je tremble
seul problème si tu l'as dit moi
qu'avons nous à la chambre elle doit
normalement attendre l'autorisation
d'utiliser son arme
ce soir là l'ordre a été donné à 19h le
policier et demi avant pris l'initiative
de tirer avant
l'ex-policier d'un esclave est favorable
aux armes d'impact mais s'étonne qu'on
les utilise avec autant d'insouciance
risquer de blesser quelqu'un pour
éliminer un manifestant qui sans
minauder quelque chose
moi je pense à ça ça vaut pas de jeu ça
vaut pas le jeu parce que tu me poses
quand même de ces désignations
et d'autres blessés il y en aura avant
l'autorisation d'utiliser les armes de
l'étudiante dominique la liberté
martineau reçoit un projectile en plein
visage un barton si laitiers qui
trouvait à ses côtés
elle souffre d'une double fracture de la
mâchoire elle s'était pourtant mis à
l'écart comme magali paquet moi j'ai je
me suis éloigné parce qu'elle va
évidemment beaucoup de gaz lacrymogène
et je suis allé à contrevent pour me
mettre à l'abri mais elle en profite
pour envoyer un statut facebook noter
l'heure 18h54 c'est à ce moment qu'elle
est frappée au bras par un projectile
et le monsieur en fait qui approche les
teams temps un objet vert s'est avéré
être un bâton cinétique
il me dit c'est ça qui vous a frappé
madame je l' ai vu c'est ce que vous a
frappé ce qui lui vaut d'avoir tiré à 20
qui vous disent qu au brésil
j'ai possédé d'amis son église
je me suis un compte viens là j'ai pour
ma vie où la vie d'un de mes confrères
utiliser mon arme à feu pour moi le jeu
partant du long métrage suit l'épopée me
dire mais là il lira ch comment cette
dangereuse tirer sans autorisation est
exceptionnel beaucoup beaucoup
d'adrénaline de stress laden la peur la
colère
c'est un cocktail explosif de kant
ménage c'est ensemble avec le celui qui
est en arrière lui il faut que je sois
au courant de ce soit conscient de ce
celui qui est en arrière c'est son chef
de peloton
denis burel avait l'obligation de la
visée à chacun de ces tirs mais il ne
l'a pas fait je te parle plus occuper
leurs protégés le lait les membres de
mon club dont quatre de ses supérieurs
ont témoigné aucun heurt et eu
connaissance que les gens burelle a tiré
dix fois
nicolas brusque au bar votre nom des
gens et c'est d'alerter l'anti émeute ou
fait qu'une personne est grièvement
blessé elles font les week-ends appelé
le 9-1-1 répondent les policiers le 2
dans sa déposition au commissaire à la
déontologie dit qu'on ne savait pas si
c'était vrai pourtant c'est vrai la vie
d'alexandre allard est menacée fracture
du crâne double commotion cérébrale son
état exige une évacuation immédiate
l'ambulance arrive un corridor s'ouvre
autour du blessé mais les policiers
chargent d'animer
[Applaudissements]
la police explique raquel tentaient
d'accéder aux blessés
la manoeuvre force l'équipe de premiers
soins et à prendre un grand risque
objet de thé place un nouveau alexandre
pour la déplacer trois fois pour le mois
alors que c'est un console d'un point de
vue de soignants de déplacer ce type de
procédure il ambulance repart sans le
patient il faudra une vingtaine de
minutes avec alexandre allard plus soit
prise en charge lui aussi recevra la
visite des policiers à l'hôpital
bombardé de questions on peut se gérer
des réponses excuse et ses alliés en
noir est ce qu'elle était qu'est ce qui
vous faisait est ce que vous vous lancer
des projectiles s'étaient un peu
tendancieux les policiers rédige sa
déclaration pour lui alors qu'il est
fortement médicamenté je n'étais pas
capable de l'aller parce que seul encore
de ma condition donc une rue pour moi
qui ai je pense que c'est moi que signer
quand même je comprenais pas là elle là
l'importance que ce document alors que
ses déclarations l'avant
il considère que cette déclaration
confuse a été utilisé par les autorités
pour remettre en question sa version des
faits c'est vraiment frustrant de voir
les policiers qu'une fois passé comme si
c'était moi en fait quitté avec rocco
zemmama situation comme si dès le départ
aucune chance que ce soit un policier
fédéral erreurs ou négligences les
agissements de la jean burelle soulève
bien d'autres questions
il est témoignée ne pas se fier à sa
mire contrairement à ce qu'on lui a
enseigné il ignore à quelle distance son
armée 0t et surtout ses rapports de tirs
plusieurs fois modifié sème la confusion
plusieurs détails sont contradictoires
dont l'heure de son premier tir je peux
pas me fier sur les rapports pour moi le
fichant profil malgré l'incohérence de
ses rapports ces tirs ont tous été
déclarés conformes aux règles et chacun
d'entre eux a été approuvé par toute sa
hiérarchie la sûreté du québec n'a pas
voulu commenter
les armes aux intermédiaires font partie
d'un arsenal militaire de plus en plus
utilisé par les policiers mais fortement
remise en question partout dans le monde
en plein coeur de new york se trouve le
siège de physicians for human rights
c'est une équipe internationale de
médecins qui recense les blessures
subies par des manifestants lorsque la
police a recours aux armes
intermédiaires maison de position que si
on utilise ses armes
on peut hériter des blessures graves ou
la mort et en fait c'est pas vrai la
meilleure arme des policiers et le
dialogue estime le docteur venters
l'expérience montre que les armes semi
létale ou des effets pervers
ces armes même avec les manifestants qui
sont pas pacifique
on voit qu'ils sont souvent utilisés
dans une maria qui qui dirige toutes les
manifestations dans une direction d'une
sens d'un pire et le s p tout à fait que
les gens qui sont placés les gens qui
meurent sont souvent des gens qui
étaient en train de manifester
pacifiquement
l'absence d'une véritable enquête sur
les blessés de victoriaville et le refus
de la police d'admettre toute
responsabilité sont typiques dit il
parce que on les appelle samy létale
moins mortel il nécessite pas le type de
formation de règles de revues après les
incidents pour voir comment un service
utilisé ces armes
[Musique]
les troubles de victoriaville conrad
harvey les a suivis de loin au coeur de
son charlevoix natale l'ancien
fonctionnaire et marin à 16 heures s'est
senti interpellé son jeune fils mathieu
a failli mourir lui aussi d'une balle de
plastique tirée par un policier en 2001
que les policiers focus chf sur la
défense du territoire et repos chez les
citoyens et il laisse porter des jeans à
gembloux xiam mais de réfléchir après 17
ans l'a fait mais accepte enfin de
révéler son histoire
[Musique]
c'est au sommet des amériques qui ont
donné leurs que des corps policiers
canadiens ont recours aux balles de
plastique lors de manifestations pour la
toute première fois
900 projectiles et 5 millions chimiques
sont tirées principalement par la sûreté
du québec et la grc
mathieu harvey venait d'avoir 16 ans
avec son ami manuel
il revient sur les lieux pour la
première fois je me souviens qu'à qu'on
a vu justement là
[Musique]
lentement plus manifestants la police
iliad empêché de monter
le 21 avril 2001 poussés par la
curiosité des années observe des
manifestations du haut de la rue saint
réal à près de la côte d'abraham
événements comme est d'envergure qui se
passait dans ma ville je voulais être là
pour voir ce qui se passe
elles sont
les policiers l'abri la scène de guerre
tout nous dit en scène d'horreur pour
mathieu canton peloton fait irruption au
coin de la rue et tire en direction de
la foule
moi je me suis con et elle le sera toi
qu'est la police a tourné le coin vers
nous on est au barça courir va derrière
moi
à partir de ce moment là j'avais encore
dans la panique
les amis sont séparés nature reçoit un
projectile en plein front c'est un
inconnu qui lui sauve la vie
il pense la blessure qui saigne
abondamment personnes sont accueillies
yo yo ils arrêtent et goûter et il
ici bien joué aux côtés de presse que
nous a raconté qu'il cherche lui de chan
chan l'ungei un foulard puis clopes il
le port il n'est pas abandonné
trois pelotons de policiers passent à
côté de lui sans intervenus l'ambiance
ne trouve pas monter la côte d'abraham
les dépôts pire encore donc fallu que je
décembre la cote à ce moment là cité 2
deux personnes pour me rendre jusqu'à
l'ambulance mangani pour bien taillé
s'était écoulé au total selon le rapport
environ deux ans
de peine et de misère il descend les 99
marches de l'escalier du faubourg pour
qu'une ambulance pour venir le chercher
even partie de montres en à peu près
gros comme ce qui était complètement
broyé puis le dormeur qu'il est petit
pas autour du servoir été déchiré les
fragments d'os ont atteint le cerveau
mais on peut pénétrer ils sont déposés
dessus donc j'avais testé ouvert les
cicatrices qui dit si je pense qu'on
peut la voir il ya marcher sur un fil
pour venir d'agglo le quelqu'un qui qui
fait quelle partie de l'ossature du
cerveau qui parti et que en a toujours
au moins un match en quart et à travers
la peau qui réchauffent autour de dieu
mais dessus pass 3 jours dans le coma
il subi deux interventions délicates il
ya peu de doutes pour lui qu'il a été
victime d'une balle de plastique mes
amis n'avaient ramené par la surpêche
taillis et ri puis j'avais justement mon
trou ici mettez en la privant
l'adversaire juste pour le fun system la
famille relate les faits à une fille si
de la sûreté du québec quelques mois
plus tard la première ronde j'ai lu avec
un policier sous tel événement je
n'avais pas l'intention je n'avais pas
l'impression qu'ils qui étaient là pour
trouver une fin fond de l'histoire jetez
plus une impression qui essayait de
s'assurer que la police soit pas mise en
cause la sûreté du québec conclut que
c'est la grc quitté probablement dans ce
secteur j'étais gosse je suis pas chef
chez honda prévoit ayant formé de
logique
conrad harvey a été indigné de voir
ensuite d'autres jeunes blessé de la
même manière pour cours du printemps
arabe après tant d'années on oublie beau
on n'avait pas appris beaucoup de shit
et pas au chômage amérique pour que les
réglages événement de deux victoires et
je vois pas comme un policier
expérimenté puis est ce qu'on me dit ce
qui ne s'est embrasée du monde frère
comme il peut arriver à la conclusion
qu'ils progressent à gratens assis dans
un top 250 personnes du bo on le met
dans les mains quelque chose on lui dgid
d'avoir un certain comportement mais ça
dérape
au terme d'une longue bataille mathieu a
été officiellement reconnue et
indemnisés en tant que victime d'un acte
criminel parce que la police ne lui a
pas porté secours
le premier se remet à nos policiers
cette porte assistance aux citoyens
donc je sais pas quand même des dizaines
de policiers formés entraînés payer pour
ce ont pu passer à côté moisins on les
drapeaux la famille a songé à intenter
une poursuite en dommages dans l'espoir
de faire changer les choses mais l'ivac
a mis tellement de temps à décider du
cas de mathieu qu'il était trop tard on
ne peut plus parce que le délai tosic au
bourget au moment où on ne rejoue la vie
comme de quoi ils étaient ils étaient
victimes de la criminelle chez paul
vidal de tous les fonctionnaires de
décider qui victime d'un acte criminel
quand possiblement le coupable c'est
l'appareil gouvernemental
en 2005 un rapport de l'école nationale
de police recommande au ministère de la
sécurité publique d'élaborer des règles
plus claires et plus contraignante pour
encadrer ces armes
[Musique]
c'est aussi une des recommandations clés
de la commission d'examen sur le
printemps étudiants elle va jusqu'à
réclamer un moratoire sur l'usagé des
balles de plastique mais le ministère
n'agira qu'en 2015
alors qu on lui recommande de permettre
larmes d'impact pour protéger contre une
menace grave et imminente susceptibles
de causer la mort ou des lésions
corporelles la règle adoptée est
beaucoup plus permissive
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être
confrontés à un danger grave ou imminent
ou de mort pour utiliser une arme qui
peut être mortelle mais imaginez 30
secondes quand des manifestants qui
étaient aux soins intensifs à l'hôpital
de trois-rivières
marc imaginez juste trente secondes de
résultats de tous pourquoi même prévoir
d'utiliser des ans qui pourrait causer
des blessures je pense qu'à la barre on
devrait se poser se sont longs depuis
victoriaville alexandre allard vite avec
des séquelles permanentes
c'est aussi le cas de dominique la
liberté martineau les deux ont poursuivi
le gouvernement et ont réglé à l'amiable
je pense qu'elle est le policier qui a
agi de cette manière là individuellement
un mal agi mais je pense que c'est plus
grand que je pense que c'est vraiment
dans la culture policière
oui il ya une question de culture
première des choses on peut pas faire
d'erreur peuvent pas un mythe qu'est ce
qu'on leur enseigne et peut-être pas
tout à fait corée devrait peut-être mode
s'y associer c'est possible
nul doute que la police sera équipé d'un
puissant personal lors du g7 prévue en
juin prochain dans charlevoix
elle se prépare depuis des mois
[Musique]
l'agent burel n'y sera pas avec son arme
d'impact le comité de déontologie
policière conclu qu'il n'a pas respecté
ses règles d'engagement à victoriaville
et que ces tirs ont causé des blessures
le policier a renoncé à son arme
d'impact en 2015
l'une des images qui ont été les plus
marquantes en marge des événements de
victoriaville c'est ce policier battus
par des manifestants
et après la pause on entend sa version
pour la première fois l'image de la
manifestation de victoriaville qui a
profondément indigné le public c'est
celle ci c'est le moment où le sergent
daniel gauvreau est battu par des
manifestants selon des informations que
nous avons obtenues
c'est que ce policier là aurait
justement était en train d'aider un
autre citoyen soigner ça c'est la
version officielle
voyons maintenant celle des policiers et
piquer presque vingt ans la
manifestation tire à sa fin
quelques manifestants s'en prennent à
des véhicules de la police stationné à
proximité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des véhicules soit point émeutes ouest
la foule pas où tu n'as tu pas en plus
il atterrit aux couleurs la sûreté
brigade le sergent daniel gauvreau
décide d'intervenir avec comme unique
protection existent par balles j'en ai
besoin je sais qu'une vue gens très
talentueux sur l'autobus il me vue bien
là mais tu ton et la roche quitte la
course longue portée a consacré le
policier agrippe le suspect et
l'entraînent au sol son geste attire
toute cette attention
mais à ce moment à la foule pour la
manette ma maison sont approchés
répugnant peut pas battre l'allemande
jour - venir en aide
le lieutenant patrick foot et saufs dans
un camion et sans lamelles sont de
vraies causes les états hôtes yayi et
qu'un pick up sorte de où c'est qui ce
fait ne se pose pas coach qui ont pensé
partir de ce moment les manifestants
redouble de violence
jean paul huchon dans la patinoire qui
pas pédaler sur les canaux qu'en fait
nous tenaille mais quand je vois la
porte pour aller ramasser daniel et j'ai
une roche qui me rappelle le dernière
bataille puis à ce moment là ben
notamment le policier côté doit se
résoudre à repartir et j'arrange dans la
foule en espérant sortir de l'eau sans
écraser personne parce que conklin vous
auriez quand le camion se retire les
choses se corsent anisé jusqu'à ce qu'un
autre policiers interviennent cette fois
avec des gaz lacrymogènes tirées plosser
château de corse et dans ce cas là lille
et chantant ali c'était l'outil utilisé
justement le sergent goudreault s'en
tire avec des ecchymoses et des
courbatures après l'incident
il sera même en mesure de compléter son
quart de travail mais il ya eu un blessé
grave
[Musique]
l'étudiant maxence balade a reçu un
projectile au visage il a perdu un oeil
il est persuadé d'avoir été atteint par
un tir policier
dans ces images jamais encore rendu
public
on voit une balle de plastique à ses
pieds la police croit qu'il a été blessé
par un autre manifestant dans les
rapports de tir on apprend que le
policier claude saint germain a tiré dix
projectiles pendant les quarante
secondes qu'a durés l'incident il écrit
je ne peux pas décrire les manifestants
avec précision par contre je peux
confirmer que j'atteignais les
manifestants au bas des jambes
ces tirs ont été jugés conformes
où que se trouve la vérité on peut se
demander si les six dans serait survenu
si le sergent goudreault n'avait pas
tenté une arrestation hier mais on
déplace album fever nous on le sait que
ce sport après manifester tu veux pas le
lâcher mais là tu peux être notion ton
environnement tout ce que tu vis seule
focus ce manifestant à la première chose
que tu peux être mené en cirque litzman
3-4-5 autour de toi te doublent les
policiers gauvreau reconnaît ne pas
avoir agi selon les règles de l'art des
caméras de ma porte champions sans jouer
j'irai lui le fait que l'utilisation de
la folie que l'on envoyait des gens là
qui n'en fait des roches qui nous est
que mon travail tant qu'à moi c'était la
mort éditions pika son manteau le blessé
poursuit la sûreté du québec le procès
reste à venir s'il vient en terminant il
ya de nouvelles études scientifiques sur
les balles en plastique alors la plus
récente vient d'être publiée par le
british medical journal nous apprend que
une personne sur six qui se présente à
l'hôpital avec une blessure causée par
un projectile comme celui ci aura des
séquelles permanentes et une sur 37 vont
mourir ça devrait faire réfléchir
alors merci beaucoup d'avoir été là au
nom de toute l'équipe on vous remercie
on espère surtout vous retrouver la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]